Hello, The Internet.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
A while ago, Dan, You
probably remember this,
we did a video with and air bag.
One air bag.
Yeah, it got 10 million views
and we thought, you know, that was fun.
Let's upscale it a little bit.
No you may think, two airbags, right?
Yeah.
Wrong.
We've rinsed a scrapyard for 25 airbags.
Yeah, we've come to this huge quarry
'cause we need a lot more space this time
and what we're gonna do is
put loads of powder paint
on each airbag and have a huge explosion
where it sort of goes from
one color to the next.
Let's go get this wired up
and make the biggest mess we've ever made.
Huge mess.
All right.
Let's go.
I think I can only carry four.
This will take several trips.
One for that one.
Okay, so we're gonna wire these up
in this sort of X shape so one's on each
edge of the--
Are they all different
sort of internally for the wiring?
Well I think they've all got
the same sort of connector.
You just nee to put
the wire onto each one.
What are the chances of any of these
going off in your hand?
Firing up through your head.
There's no power source
connected at the other end
so they theoretically are perfectly safe.
Okay.
Excited about the Merc.
I think that's gonna be a good one.
You think so?
That's some high-end airbag,
that there, isn't it?
Didn't they invent airbags?
Did they?
Yeah.
They invented a lot of stuff.
It's actually invented by Dave Airbag
from the 60s.
So that's how they got the name.
Whoo!
How exactly are you doing this?
Just wrap it around twice?
So what you have to do
is wrap it around and then
sort of squeeze it in,
into the middle like this
so that it's quite tight
on the actual airbag.
I just like now suddenly realized,
that is a lot to the extent of the mess
we're about to make.
Yeah, we can't
let his tip over.
Like that alone
would be too much mess to clean up
and we've got 23 more to fill.
I'm a bit nervous.
Oh, me too.
You're nervous? I'm nervous
that they won't all go off.
Like what, if they're
not connected properly?
Yeah.
Or how we mess this up?
Oh, this one's a bit bigger.
There you go.
This is gonna make a big mess. Whoop.
So it looks like we're all
primed and ready to go.
Yes we are, yeah.
I'm trying to decide
where we're gonna stand.
Originally we wanted to be
stood, you know, sort of
in the middle looking really bad-ass
as it all, pew.
Not looking at explosions.
Yeah.
Sort of having it
in the background but then
I came up with the point
that essentially we've put a lot
of airbags next to each other
and at any point one could
go off and hit another one
sort of forwards into
the back of my skull.
So we'll do it twice
and we'll determine if
it's safe to stand in there
based on our first take.
And if not, you know, we'll
just cower behind the camera.
Okay, go for it.
You ready?
Yeah.
'Kay.
So I'm taking the nail out.
Ready?
Yeah.
Three, two, one.
Go!
Whoa.
Did we miss red and purple?
Looks like it.
Yeah, it definitely hit all the nails.
Whoa.
We made a me--
Look at it!
What happened?
Wow!
That looks awesome, doesn't it?
This looks so cool.
It's actually a really
lovely turquoise green.
It is, it mixes up with--
Purple,
purple didn't go off.
No.
Yellow didn't go off.
Well no.
One of the yellow went off.
Look.
One yellow one.
One yellow went off.
All the greens, all the blues
and none of the other ones went off.
So...
This looks awesome, though.
Phew, phew.
Okay, let's review the slom.
Oh wow, that was a great
delay between them actually.
One of the yellows went off and only one.
You know, one yellow
looks like four yellows.
It does, to be fair.
I mean, that is slightly thicker
but that still looks awesome.
Two pounds of paint, that's why.
Is that an airbag up there?
Yeah!
The yellow airbag took off.
So that was excellent.
We did a really good job there.
A sort of 50% failure there.
Well.
Less than half
of them went off.
Yeah, I mean.
We got two colors to go off well.
The rest of them didn't
even go off at all.
I will say, we made art
that bloody Neil Buchanan
would be proud of.
He would be proud of that, bless his soul.
Well he's not dead.
There's always that he's dead.
Isn't it?
There's always rumors.
Alright, so we're gonna change it up
to hopefully increase our success rate.
The one yellow that went
off actually kicked up
a hell of a lot of paint.
So let's just use two airbags per color.
It will still be a hell of a lot.
And also reduce our
point to failure by 50%.
'Kay.
Dan, I'm doing a hero pose.
Nice lunge.
Three, two, one.
Yeah!
Whoo!
That was awesome.
One of the coolest
rainbows I've ever seen in my life.
That was really successful.
That was really cool.
That was phenomenal.
The timing was great too.
Like, .
That was perfect.
So we're gonna make one
more change in the lighting.
So right now we're back
lit like that shot was.
So there's not so much detail on our faces
and it's quite--
Right, we look bad-ass
as silhouettes though.
Yeah, we look like cool silhouettes
so this time we're gonna
change it 'round. Move around
and change the set so we're
front-lighting the airbags.
Yeah, so the main puff of color
should be a little bit more bright.
And we're also gonna shove
an angle in from the side.
Coming towards the camera
which should look a mental war movie.
Yeah, it'll be really cool.
Just really colorful.
This is the last one.
Right, you're gonna jump
and time it correctly.
I'm gonna try and do a
really cool jump mid-air.
Cool.
Wait, jump mid-air?
Who jumps in mid-air?
I'm gonna try and do a really cool jump
mid explosion.
Sweet.
So I'm just lingering,
you know?
I'm just gonna sort of do
this and then look cool.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
I'm ready.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
Right.
Three, two, one.
Go!
Whoa!
That was slightly disconcerting.
Flip.
All I heard was this,
and then I heard like
wood falling to the floor.
I was just like
what is going on?
How's my back?
Is it good?
Ah, you're good, yeah.
That wasn't bad.
I think we timed it right.
I don't think my face looks very cool
as I'm jumping.
Just scowling.
You're really concerned.
I'm like.
Aw, man.
When we practiced it,
it seemed to be alright
but it's so quick that you've
not even like taken off there.
That's ridiculous.
I'm a lot slower
than I thought.
It is wicked though.
Look at that shot.
That's so cool.
That's like a new background for our,
that's a desktop background
right there.
That is cool.
I'm unsure of my face right there.
I was sort of just like
concentrating as soon
as I turned the lever.
Uhh.
What I've noticed
is the funniest thing about slow motion
is that if you ever do something
and try to look in the lens,
you never nail the lens
first so you're always
looking off.
Yeah, yeah.
And it lasts forever in
slow mo. You're just looking
in the wrong place.
Like where's he looking?
That's how you make a rainbow.
That looks massive.
These explosions
could be huge.
Explode a rainbow.
Oh-ho, that is...
That is one of my favorite things
that we've ever filmed.
That is so cool.
This angle, I didn't think it
would look, I knew it would
look cool, but.
The fact that you
can get such a cool looking thing
for such a tiny period of time.
Like, that was cool for
probably 0.01 seconds.
That's wicked.
Hey, yep, yep.
Oh, that was terrible, come on.
Do you wanna do it better?
You have to look at, look at my elbow.
Alright ready?
Yeah.
Alright, look at my elbow.
Well Dan, I think visually, that was one
of the most delicious
things we've ever filmed.
That shot of all the colors
coming towards the camera.
What, like the bombing run?
Yeah.
The misty man bombing run?
If the Muppets decided
to go on a bombing run
in the desert.
That was so cool.
It's amazing.
Phantom took it in the nose.
Oh, standard.
Placed it downwind,
there's a bit of paint on the lens there.
But nothing a good cloth won't fix.
First of all, I didn't get hurt.
You didn't get hurt.
Which is good.
And I don't have to clean
up 'cause we're in a quarry.
That's true. The rain
will just wash this away.
Yes, yes.
We obviously gotta deal
with these airbags.
There's a lot of those.
I kinda want to put a canvas
underneath it and do it again.
And then just like.
So we can keep it?
Moisten is to make it
so it's actually paint
rather than powder paint.
In a way, it'd be cool
to just walk into a room
with like four different
airbags and different colors.
Glue the walls and then just set,
it's be like Mr. Bean painting a room.
Well hopefully you thought
that video was lovely.
And be sure to follow us
on Twitter, buy some merch.
Obviously if Dan sees you
wearing a Slow Mo Guys shirt
he will buy you a drink.
That is number one Slow Mo rule.
And be sure to subscribe to the channel.
We have a second channel too.
Get that one as well.
Collect them all.
See you next time.